they have a quarterback who has more
power and leverage than we realize dak
prescott has no obligation to sign a
long-term deal with the dallas cowboys
he does he can do the kirk cousins thing
you want to franchise tag me next year
fine you want to franchise tag me here
after that fine at some point i'm
forcing my way out if i want out here's
my thought here's my because we we heard
dak prescott earlier this week say talk
is cheap and you know he's never going
to say anything that would get himself
in any trouble but you have to wonder at
what point at what point does he say
enough
i th this is not a functional football
franchise i don't want to be here
anymore if the owner's going to talk to
the media three times a week and create
these distractions in the locker room
and undermine the players undermine the
coach embrace the coach every week it's
something different i don't want to be
part of this i want to be part of a
football team that has a winning culture
and this team ultimately at its core
does not have a winning culture because
it's more about selling the sizzle then
then crafting the best possible steak
what do you think about those all right
so the first take i don't even think was
like
even remotely a hot take i think it was
just 100 fact the jerry jones likes to
be in the media likes to give the
cowboys relevancy even if they haven't
been relevant to win a championship in
25 years so that one you're spot on the
second one dak prescott
i can see it but i still think that
being the cowboys the dallas cowboys
quarterback comes there comes value in
that like you are
kind of similar to the first take jerry
jones makes the cowboys relevant even if
they aren't relevant on the field the
cowboys quarterback being that position
will always have some relevance whether
it be marketing american culture
whatever you want to say so
that positive
would outweigh the possible negatives
and it's one of those things where it's
just part of the deal you're going to be
the cowboys quarterback everyone's going
to know your name whether you're the
best quarterback in the league or not
you're going to be in a discussion in
the narrative around the league and with
that comes your owner talking to the
media all the time and having the
cowboys be a circus at times especially
when things go poorly
okay i can throw one more ingredient
into the mix that will turn up the heat
of the take considerably are you ready
for it are you sitting down of course
you're sitting down there's like baking
soda in like a in like a fifth grade
volcano right exactly yeah it's it's
it's meant to it's mentos in coke zero
okay is that what it is is that how it
does it is it mentos
don't pretend that you're not in your
backyard in west virginia making viral
videos
all right uh there's a team out there
that has a platform sort of like the
cowboys that has a winning culture
that's going to be looking for a
quarterback in the next year or two
i don't wait wait
wait
are you gonna go with the raiders
because i have something that are you
gonna go with the raiders no no no no no
no i'm talking about the patriots talk
about that okay i thought you were i
thought you were i thought you were
talking about the patriots i thought
maybe you're going to zig on that talk
about the patriots i mean look at
because look the patriots are the
anti-cowboys they're not creating these
distractions the owner doesn't go out
and bluster every week about this that
or the other thing and we got out
coached and the players got that no it's
a well-oiled machine
it's a group of players that find a way
to achieve more than they can
individually that's one of the problems
with the cowboys jerry jones has finally
put together a great roster when you
look at it player for player but they're
not playing together the way that they
need to whether that's coaching whether
that's you know hey it's one thing to
look at the player in isolation but how
is that player going to fit with the
other 50 players in the locker room and
trust me that is a huge part of team
building at an nfl level some teams get
it and some teams don't and a team that
would be most likely to not get it is
the team where the owner bought it and
made himself the general manager and it
never worked in a football operation
before that so i i just think that
and i don't know this is it's just fun
to talk about it fun to think about but
if i'm dak prescott if i'm dak prescott
at some point i'm going to be at my
wit's end with this and if there is
another team out there that's kind of
like the cowboys from my profile
standpoint i can still make my dan and
yogurt money and whatever other
endorsements he has my sleep number bed
and this that and the other thing i'm i
i'm i'm they need a quarterback look we
just assume the patriots are going to
groom some fifth round draft pick to be
the successor to tom brady why are we
being so narrow in our thought about
what they may try to do post tom brady
why not pluck a guy who's been developed
by someone else
okay so for the people watching at home
mike florio in back-to-back days has
given you andrew luck who is currently
retired
as starting quarterback of the las vegas
raiders in 2020 and then
if you thought that wasn't enough he
gave you dak prescott to be the patriots
quarterback of the future mike
no one in the history of the world has
needed
like some kind of legal drama with the
nfl more than you right now your brain
is going crazy you're a dog without
exercise you're just running around
you're going to chew all the shoes
you're going to say everyone's going
everywhere you're crazy let me tell you
something though
if i had told you in february 2008 the
day after brett favre went through a
case of tissues retiring from the
packers that he'd be the starting
quarterback of the vikings
the following year 2009 you would have
thought it was just as crazy i mean the
point is we have seen a bunch of crazy
crap
and there's nothing wrong with expanding
the mind without taking any
mind-expanding drugs that anyone knows
of and just thinking about what can
happen i'm just saying if i'm dak
prescott i'm getting to the point where
i've had enough and if he has had enough
uh he's got options he's got leverage
and he does not have to stay with the
cowboys for the rest of his career
that's all i'm saying let's take a break
yeah we gotta we gotta sell your brain
chemistry to like bill walton or
something because there's something
wrong with your brain we're gonna do
we're gonna do so well you're just
figuring that out now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports